ارجنتيني يحلم بحمل ميسي بعد مارادونا هو
مشاركه ويجز في ختام المونديال تثير الجدل
والغضب في بريطانيا يتصاعد على هاري وميغا
اهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
اليوم بدات توقيت حلقتنا مع بدايه ونهايه
حدث عالمي شاغل الناس والدنيا من 20
نوفمبر وبدايه المباراه النهائيه بين
منتخبي الارجنتين وفرنسا على لقب بطل كاس
العالم 20 22 في نهايه مونديال شغل العالم
طول شهر بالمنافسه والمفاجاه طبعا هو
مشاهدينا المنتخبين الحاصلين مرتين على
لقب بطل الكاس العالم والمنافسه اليوم
لنيل النجمه الذهبيه الثالثه
اليوم وحملات الدعم للفريقين من الصوت
وشغله عقول وقلوب الملايين اما الين المسي
قال له ان نصيب الاكبر من الدعم اليوم
ويبدو انه السبب بالاضافه لانجازاته
وبهارات الكبيره اللي قدمها لمنتخبه
وانديه كره العالم او لكره القدم العالميه
بشكل عام يبدو انه كمان هذه المباراه راح
تكون اخر مباراه بيخوضها في كاس العالم
فهذا كمان عامل
هذا نوع من الحماس لكن بشكل عام الاجواء
الحماسيه والخصوصيه الرياضيه والحاله اللي
يعملها المونديال حقيقه ما بتتكرر لانه
بالاساس صعب يكون في حدات يجمع الملايين
على متابعته همم بنفس الحماس من اول يوم
لاخر دقيقه في جالسه وكثير من المتعصبين
لكره القدم من بعد ما بينتهي المونديال
بيعانوا من الوحده والعصبيه والكابه بسبب
الفراغ وخروج جدول النشاطات من موضوعات
شيقه ما فيشعر باكتئاب ما بعد البطوله
بوست تورنا من دب فعلا مصطلح للموضوع يعني
واللي من اعراضه الحزن والكسل وقضاء ساعات
في متابعه اخبار اللاعبين المصابين
وتنقلاتهم واحتفالات الفريق اللي فاز وهذه
الاعراض حلها يا جماعه كالتاليه يعني لازم
يتجنب الشخصيه لاني زعلان من اصحابه بعد
المونديال لازم يمارسن نشاطات جماعيه ما
يهمل العمل او الدراسه وفي نفس الوقت ما
يشوف اعاده مباريات
الحواس الرياضي بخليه يحزن اكثر يعني بكل
بساطه يحاويه يرجع لحياته يعني عادي كيف
ما كانت قبل المونديال واذا مستغربين انه
فعلا في ناس عندها هذا النوع من الادمان
فتعالوا اسمعوا اللي عملوا مشجع ارجنتيني
علشان يشوف مباراه نصف النهائي ثم تشجع
عمره 53 سنه كان رايح على منزله بحفله نقل
جماعي ومتحمس لي مشاهده مباراه نصف
النهائي بين الارجنتين وكرواتيا عندي
اشاره المرور اخبرهم السائق انه راح يتوقف
عشان يشتري شيء وبالفعل نزل السائق من
الحفله فشعر نشجع الارجنتيني بالاحباط
والحزن انه ما عاد هيلحق المباراه يعني بس
عاد ما كان منه الا انه قام وقاعد ما كان
السائق واخذ الحفله ساق فيها وبالركاب
اللي فيها كمان واخذها مسافه كده اربع
كيلو متر وقف قريب من بيته ونزل منه ودخل
يتفرج على المباراه لكن يا فرحه ما تمت
لانه بعد دقائق من دخوله للبيجات الشرطه
وقبضت عليه لانه طبعا سائق الحافله الاصلي
بلغ اختطاف الحفله بالركاب فبكل الاحوال
الرجل ما شاف المباراه على العموم نبقى في
اجواء الحماس كاس العالم لكن عنوان مختلف
شويه وهو ازمه غناء ويجز طبعا هو يعني شاب
مصري ومغني راب معروف جدا وله شعبيه كبيره
واللي صار انه تم الاعلان عن مشاركته في
الحفله الختامي لمونديال كاس العالم في
قطر ولعت الدنيا تهاني وتبريكات انه شاب
مصري
مهم وبيستنون الناس كل اربعه سنوات وطلعت
اخبار انه النقابه قالت انه لازم ياخذ
تصريح من النقابه قبل ما يغني في كاس
العالم وهنا زعلوا الناس من النقابه وحتى
في مشاهير انتقدوا القرار الفيفا اصدرت
يوم السبت بيان عن جدول الحفل الختامي
اللي راح يستمر 15 دقيقه ووصفته انه راح
يكون حفل خالد في ذاكره 88000 متفرج داخل
استاذ والبيان عنوان ولا تتاخر ولا
تتاخروا الحفل الختام قطر 20 20 22 يشعل
حماسه الجما في استاذ لوسيل وتم استعراض
الفقرات الغنائيه اللي راح تتضمن توليفه
موسيقيه من الاغاني الرسميه للبطوله
بيان الفيفا ما جاب اي سيره لمشاركه ويكس
في الحفله الختامي وهذا الشيخ الجدل يكبر
والتنبؤات تكثر لكن مدير اعماله عاصم تاج
امس طلع مع الزميل عمرو اديب برنامج
الحكايه
ونسف كل الروايات السابقه واكد انه وجزر
رح يشارك في حفل الختامي او في همم انه
خلال اخر مباراه يعني
انا الاستاذ عصام تاج عاصم تاج صاحب شركه
تي ام تي ام ومدير اعمال ويجز اهلا بك يا
فندم
العمليه اخبارك ايه الحمد لله انت الوحيد
اللي ممكن بقى تقول لنا اين سيكون ويجز
وماذا سيحدث غدا
اللاعيبه هتخش تقعد في اللوكر بقى
هيطلع على الناس في الملعب ويغني
ويكذب صاحبه لحمه هيطلع يغني الاغنيه في
الاستاذ قدام الجماهير
وبعدين هيخش على الفصل
على التلفزيون
الاغنيه كامله وبعدين يكمله
الحفل النهائي لكاس العالم
مدير اعماله انه بين الشوطين في ستوري
للمغني نفسه كان ناشرها من ساعتين تقريبا
على صفحته وبيظهر فيها متواجد فيه استاذ
لوسيل
من عبر الهاتف من القاهره مصطفى كامل نقيب
المهن الموسيقيه في مصر اهلا فيك معانا
استاذ مصطفى انا حابه اتكلم معاك عن حمله
الهجوم اللي تم شنها على النقاب على
عقيل انه بسبب معارضتها لموضوع غناء اذا
تقدر توضح لي موقف النقابه من هذا الموضوع
موقف النقابه واضح وصريح واعلنكم
انا باكلمك دلوقت من داخل نقابه المجتمع
بمجلس الاداره بالكامل كلنا بنوع
وترحيبنا وتهنئتنا لاي انسان او فنان مصري
يمثل مصر بالخارج طيب شرف كبير لينا
وبنقعد كل الدعم وكل المحبه وكل التقدير
وربنا يوفقه وربنا يكرمه ده موقف مصطفى
كامل الشخصي والنقيب ومجلس اداره نقابه
التنميه كل ما طرح عبر وسائل الاعلام
احنا لم نعلن عنها وادخلت القبض البيانات
لم تصدرها كلها على غير الحقيقه وكلها
عاريه تماما من الصحه نحن ندعم اي انسان
مصري اي فنان مصري اي رياضي مصري
في اي محسن ما بيشرفنا ويشرف بلدنا
هذا اللبس صار بسبب القصه انه اللي ذكرتوه
او التصريح اللي صدر منكم قبل كده انه
ويجز ما جالي النقابه واجتمع معكم لما
اجتمعتوا مع الفنانين الفنانين النمو عضو
مسجل في النقابه
اذا حضرتك
خبر
[موسيقى]
مصري ده موضوع ثاني خالص كل ما اطير من
جاد العبره وسائل التواصل او القنوات
[موسيقى]
اوك كل ما اعلن وما اثير حول اا اغنيه كاس
العالم كلها اخبار عاريه تماما
بين غناء ويجز في كاس العالم وبين الشان
الداخلي اللي هو عدم مثلا اخراجه لبطاقه
النقابه او ما الى ذلك اللي هي عن غناؤه
في مصر
اللي بيتقال ان همم ان هذا الشاب ربنا
كارمه بره في الخارج لما يرجع باذن الله
ينتمي لها ويوقع على كافه الاقرارات
والتعهدات اللي مضى عليها كل شعبه الرياض
اهلا به طبعا ومرحب به في بلده في نقابه
الموسيقيه كشب الممثلنا وشاب حق نجاح
جماهيري كبير شرف كبيره وشرف لمصر كلها
داخل مصر
ان شاء الله هيجي باذن الله هو ابننا
وهيجي باذن الله ما فيش حاجه اسمها
لغايه دلوقتي بنقول هو لا لم ينتمي الى
شعبه الراب طبقا لما قرروا مجلس الاداره
بالاجماع من الغاء كافه التصريح اللي كانت
سابقه على ان يجي يمضي يقرا له تعهد كل
شباب جاءت وانا اعتقد ان هو اللي شغله
ممكن يكون حفلاته في الخارج ربنا يوفقه ده
اول ما يجي هنا احنا كلنا في انتظاره ده
ابننا ومرحب به جدا شكرا لك على هذه
المداخله وهذا التوضيح كان معنا عبر
الهاتف من القاهره مصطفى كامل نقيب المهن
الموسيقيه في مصر
نبقى مشاهدينا في اخبار كاس العالم
والحماس الكبير اللي خلى الناس ترجع 36
سنه وتتذكر المشجع الارجنتيني روبرتو
سيغاس الحمل مارادونا على اكتافه في 86
وبيحلم اليوم انه يحمل مسيكم كمان واللي
اللي بيسال مثلا ايش يعني بعد 36 عام وهلت
عيد التاريخ نفسه
بالتحديد في لانه ببساطه هذه الرجل سافر
في 86 من الارجنتين الى المكسيك عشان يحضر
المباراه النهائيه لكاس العالم بين
الارجنتين والمانيا من دون ما تكون معه
تذكره حضور للمباراه يعني انتم متخيلين في
هذا الوقت اون لاين ولا شيء يعني كثير صعب
الموضوع من الممثل الرجال على المكسيك
وقدر انه يتسلل يدخل الملعب قومه بس كده
كمان قدر انه يحشر كده نفسه ضمن الحشود
ويشيل مارادونا على اكتافه وحامل كاس
العالم وهذا الشيخ اللاعب كره القدم
الارجنتيني مارتن الناس وكان نوع يعني من
التفاعل والاحتفال المسبق سلوفرته سيغسلي
الى قطر لحضور المباراه النهائيه بس في
اختلاف واحد انه هذه المره معه تذكره
وكمان هذه المره في حلم بيحلم فيه روبرتو
وهو انه كمان يحمل ميسي مثل ما حمل
مارادونا في 86
احلى من جديد انتهت منصه نتفلك من عرض
الحلقات الثلاثه الاخيره
من بعد ما تم عرض اول ثلاث حلقات فالجدل
والانتقاد والغضب ما زال سيد المشهد ولكن
دوز الصدمات والمفاجات والادعاءات
والروايات في الحلقات هذه الثلاثه الاخيره
زاد كثير
حرب النجوم
سبونج بوب
[موسيقى]
لما يجي المعاقه اهو طب رونج رويوس
نورس اصبر
[موسيقى]
الاميره الملك
هذا تفجر موجه كبيره من الغضب بين الناس
اللي اعتبروه تعدي واضح وصريح على الملك
الراحله والعائله المالكه ككل وانه الهدف
منه الكسب المالي وبالفعل في كثير من
الاخبار عن حصد الثنائي للكثير من المكاسب
الماديه مقابل الفيلم وارتفعت المطالبات
الشعبيه والرسميه بتجريد الامير هاري
وميجن من القابهم كدوق وذوقه ساسكس ولكن
لليوم ما في اي تعليق واضح وصريح من القصر
الملكي ولكن في شيء واحد لفت الناس وعامل
لهم صدمه انه في مصادر ملكيه قالت انه على
الرغم من كل اللي صار لكن الملك تشارلز
بيمد غصن الزيتون للامير هاري وزوجته ولا
زال ناوي يدعوهم لحضور مراسم حفله تنصيبه
وكمان ملك للبلاد في السادس من مايو وانه
ما زال مرحب بذوق وذوقه قصص سكس في القصر
وعلى فكره هذه مو اول ولا هتكون اخر مره
الامير هاري وما يقلب الدنيا بتصيحاتهم
واخبارهم لسه كمان هيكون عندنا ازمه جديده
في يناير وهو موعد كتاب الامير هاري
المثير للجدل اللي بيحمي الاسم سبير او
البديل في اشاره الى انه كائن الثاني
للملك فهو مجرد بديل في حال صار اي شيء
لاخوه الاكبر والمعلومات متاكد انه في قلق
وترصد للكتاب لانه بيتضمن معلومات خاصه
وانتقادات للنظام الملكي وتفاصيل
المكالمات بين الامير وجدته الراحله
الملكه اليزابيث الثانيه قبل وفاه ابي
فتره قصيره وحسب التقارير الاعلاميه
الامير هاري حصل على مقدم بقيمه 20 مليون
دولار كجزء من صفقه ب 38 مليون دولار
مقابل نشر المذكره
عن كل هذا الغضب فيه بريطانيا رسميا
وشعبيا تنظم الينا من لندن جوسلين اللي هي
المحرره في صحيفه الشرق الاوسط اهلا فيك
معنا جوسيليني يعني دائما قاعده القصر
والعائله الملكيه البريطانيه انه لا تشتكي
لا تعلق او لا ترد على اي شيء
كسره هذه القاعده اشتكوا وعلقوا ولكن
القصر مستمر في الصمت الى متى هيستمر
القصر في الصمت وهذه الادعاءات كل ما لها
بتكبر وتكبر
صحيح اللي قلتي ساره ولكن هالمره يعني
الشكوى كانت على نيه جدا وكانت مقابل مبلغ
مادي كبير جدا هذا بس اذا تكلمنا عن
السلسله اللي كانت من ست حلقات يلا حكيتها
عنا بالمقدمه هي اللي قبض علي الامير هاري
وزوجته 100 مليون دولار هذا غير الكتابه
[موسيقى]
ضخمه جدا غير مسبوقه يعني هي مش اول مره
بيكون في انتقادات بيكون في مشاكل داخل
القصر من ايام ليدانا باوائل التسعينات
وانهيار زواج من الاميره تشارلزلي اصبح
اليوم ملك هذا منا اول مره ولا راح تكون
اخر مره ولكن المساله التمييز العنصري
والاتهامات الكبيره اللي عم بتصير هلا همم
يعني حبينا او لا هو قلنا ايه او لا بتاذي
بشكل كبير الى زعزعه الى صوره العائله
الملكيه همم بريطانيا عشان كده انا
مستغربه صراحه من صمت الكبير والكلام الان
اللي بيتم او بيقال يبدو انه
الارجنتين الارجنتين دخلوه هدف ضربه جزاء
واحد صفر نفسي داخل الهدف همم طيب عشان لا
انا عشان بس باوضح كمان الموضوع اللي طلع
ورائي انا مع مين انا مو فارق عندي اليوم
احد من الاثنين يعني فا فا عادي اوكي انا
انا قادره اعرف من الصريخ تحديدا مين من
زملائي اللي بيصرخوايا جوسيلين لهدرجه بس
المهم خلينا نرجع ليه موضوعنا انا كنت
بقول لك انه غريب جدا عدم تعليق الملك على
الموضوع لانه فعلا انت هم بيتهموا الان
المؤسسه ككل فهل طبيعي انه يرجعوا بعدين
يعزموهم على حفله تتويج وانه لازال يقدر
يتعامل مع ك- ابن
همم بتاكد انا بافتكر انه راح يجوا راح
يحضر حفله تتويج مثل المسار لما توفي
حضروا ولكن حضور كان يعني غير محدد حتى من
افراد العائله يعني حضروا القصر همم بس بس
انتهيت المراسم
يكون هالشي نفس الشيء خاصه مثل ما انت
ذكرت انه الملك تشارلز مش عم بيتخلى عنك
فرصه انهن يرجعوا يمكن يفكروا بالموضوع
خاصه
نشرح بدون يعني المعلومات اللي عم بيعطوها
همم القشره يعني عم بيبيعوا قصص عائليه
خاصه جدا وهي منها عائله هذه عائله ملكيه
عريقه من اهم العائلات بالعالم تبيعوا
القصص العائليه الخاصه فيهم ولكن هذا
الشيء هذا مش راح يستمر يعني نحن عشنا هل
ست حلقه وبلشنا همم
[موسيقى]
الان في حتى كميه يعني انتقادات اول حتى
كان مثلا في امريكا كان عندهم شعبيه اكبر
خلينا نقول من بريطانيا الان حتى في
امريكا في انتقادات كبيره لهم وفي تعليق
انه انتم كنتم تبغوا خصوصيه انتم قلتم لكم
الحياه فيها حريه العائله المالكهلكه مضت
في طريقها وانتم لازلتوا تعلكم في نفس
الموضوع
بالفعل هيك يعني من ثلاثه ايام
تقريبا صار في استطلاع للراي بي اميركا
مثل ما انت قلتي واتبين انه شعبيته انخفضت
جدا يعني الى الحديد وهلا هالشي هيدا
انعكس اجابه على مين على خيو الامير
وزوجته الاميره كاثرين الاميرات ويلز يعني
كل شيء مش عم بيصب لمصلحتهن تمام التدخل
الرسم الوحيد كان من رئيس الحكومه
هناك لاول مره بيتدخل بهذا الموضوع
من العام المقبل راح بيكون في رقابه على
نتفليكس لانه لغايه هذه اللحظات ماشي على
نت فلكس يعني يحطه
اللي بدنا اياه مثل ما صار مسلسل
[موسيقى]
دراما مستمره معانا نحنا بنشكرك كات مع
نجوى سيلين ايليا المحرره في صحيفه الشرق
الاوسط شكرا لك يا جوسيلين
مشاهدينا احنا وصلنا الى ختام حلقه اليوم
اعود والقاكم غدا ان شاء الله في حلقه
جديده من التفاعل لكم في امان الله
[موسيقى]